so so Dean what something no one knows
about George if you were gonna tell us
that you don't have social media yeah
you don't have social media no I thought
how do you get away with that I just
never had it I got I had Facebook at
school and then I wasn't using it so I
got rid of it and I remember when
Twitter started I remember my friend
came around because I have you seen this
like it's basically like Facebook
statuses but you can read celebrities
Facebook statuses and no okay
I just never I never got on it so I've
yeah you know but maybe it's a good
thing because I've seen some of those
selfies there and would you let your
parents take over your well not yours
would you let you don't have one but if
you did have one would you like it more
in a million years no I don't know what
the post I'd be the worst thing I don't
know the unknown I feel like my mother
would be hilarious like it would just be
random things and she didn't realize she
posted it and it would be great I feel
like it's something I'm gonna do on
Mother's Day I'm gonna have her take
over my social media yeah it's gonna be
like just chaos she wouldn't know that
she posted I remember my mom my dad the
first camera phone that he had my mom
looked at it the wrong way around well
my god it's a camera and she looked down
the lens like something's wrong with
this phone I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this